that is the best smile
yeah we'd be smiling too little guy you
want some
gotta show up show love so support my
kids gotta have money not just me
well no selfishness seen here offset
showing just that on Instagram his and
cardi B's son wave playing with some new
toys that don't come cheap but nothing
in this world that I like more than
checks
of course mom and dad are known for
their lavish gifts I got some big big
things on the way big things remember
cultures present when she turned four
would you say
yeah
the caves get better every year but this
but this time seems no occasion was
needed to let wave live his best life
[Music]
that is the best smile
you want some
it's a pricey playtime like cardi to
gush in the comments quote my baby I was
born a flex diamonds on my neck this
comes as offset's already been earning
some major dad points
that's the Migos rapper and Little Wave
last week who's the new guy danger this
is unbelievable making me Spider-Man
across the spider-verse red carpet a
family affair complete with offset's
other two sons 13 year old Jordan and
eight-year-old Cody
while the fam likely set out to channel
Michael Jackson at the Marvel premiere
the inspiration for this daddy
daughter's day out was a little more
illegal I want to be where the people
are offset went full Royal on the little
mermaid's blue carpet alongside his
Disney Princesses Kalia and culture who
stepped out in black and white ball
gowns
oh
the sisters even met Hallie Bailey's
Sister Chloe and later inside culture
got a one-on-one with Ariel herself
[Music]
yep not all Precious Moments come with a
price tag but even when they do we've
got to admit that a smile like this is
money well spent
[Music]
that is the best smile